hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a how to play video for the new
scrubby dubby saga from King comm and
this game is in stock launch lap now but
it's getting really close to looking
done so I've been playing it for a while
and thought I would give you an idea of
how it works so real quick we go into
level 1 this is the first and simplest
goal type it which is to collect a
certain number of each of the soaps
which is what you know the candies or
whatever they would be in other games so
here it tells us real quick we just drag
the row match-three soap to the same
color so we we click we hold in the
slide it's real simple but if you can
see that it makes for a very different
dynamic than a regular match 3 or
collapse match 3 because the whole row
moves whenever we move candy and that
means that we can't match in the way
that we used to all right so this is
another one of the level types and it's
to free the friends and it also shows us
about these blockers they're called
sand castles and then it shows us how to
break through that so I'm gonna go ahead
and play we're gonna make we're gonna
match ourselves next to the blockers and
you can see they go away
these get layered up higher of course
like all blockers and all games do and
one of the things I want to talk to talk
to you guys about is the specials and
these are made when you match three or
more together at the same time like
right here I'm gonna make a vertical
match of 4 I'm also gonna rescue the
friend on the side because the Purple's
will line up with that but as you can
see we get a special and we actually get
our bonus special on the side now these
these used to look different
and they were a little bit easier in my
opinion to tell what they did before but
these ones that are like the puffer fish
they're gonna blow up the things in the
same area like you know like a square
sort of like a rap candy would I guess
in candy crush I'm gonna make another
one right here by matching the five the
green the five greens are gonna make me
another one of these we've got another
bonus one on that too so those are gonna
you know like if I hit this one which I
guess I'll just do it's going to
actually instead of doing that I'm gonna
oh yeah I'm gonna do that it's a how-to
video so you see it just it just blows
up a square now another thing that's
cool this is this pink one that's facing
horizontally are left and right that
will actually go side to side it'll take
out one row so we can we can look at
that and
this one that I'm gonna make here would
make the the partner of that one which
will be an up and down but it's going to
combine that this other one to make a
vague up-and-down so whenever you
combine the puffer fish and well I don't
know if that's actually what it is but
it looks like it's a puffer fish to me
when you match this together with a
striped one literally to make one that
I'll take a wide row going up if it's a
vertical one like this or a left and
right one I'm just gonna go ahead and
clear that out and so whenever I click
on this you'll see that you can combine
them together it's gonna fire it's going
to take out these three rows it's gonna
rescue my last friend and it's also
gonna set off this one so get an idea
how that works so when we look at the
scrubby w/e map you can see they have
different kinds on we had this first
type that we were just we played first
it has sort of like a hippo looking face
on it I guess that's the one where you
collect the different colors we have the
one looks like an alligator that is the
one we just played that with rescue your
friends and then we see the next one on
the map it's a squid and this is to feed
the baby jelly fishes so I guess it's
not a squid but jelly fish in this level
type we have plankton or fish food on
the ground on some of the squares and we
have to spread it out
to get it to these baby jellyfish and
you can see we start this one with some
specials already on the floor - this is
the vertical line blaster the square
line blaster and we'll make some other
ones too
but you can see we have this this
plankton stuff down here and we have
sandcastle blockers blocking it so we
want to go ahead and clear all this out
so we can spread this and this is a lot
like the you make matches next to it it
spreads it out it's a lot like the gym
in candy crush soda so it's pretty cool
now that we have this special next to it
you'll see we can use that spread it all
out and to actually rescue these we need
to get a match right next to him so
let's talk a little bit about matching
here you can see we have the simple side
to side it can roll all the way down it
kind of reminds me of one of the games
they had on Royal games and I can't
think in the name of right now but it's
it's a pretty cool mechanic it's a lot
different than then the normal match
three with a swipe or like I said the
collapsing earlier and we'll get rid of
these two blockers here by making those
matches when you see one of those got
popped and so now we just need to make
matches in the general area of these
like this green match here I'll scroll
that over that'll save that one we have
the vertical line blaster and the right
spot to save that one and we can make a
combo line blaster here that we need to
move over and this wall I'm not actually
sure because we have a nice blocker in
the way the ice blockers are the same as
these I'm not sure if this will spread
it on this row and that'll be good
and that'll do that the next level type
we see on the map is the one with the
bubbles here and it's a remove all the
foam so go ahead and look at this remove
all the foam
there'll be foam spread around the board
like so and it tells us we match soaps
to remove the foam underneath and this
is similar to a lot of different level
types and in games so we just make
matches obviously making specials will
be better than not making specials so
we'll go ahead and try to make a couple
of those I was gonna combine these
together but instead I'm gonna go ahead
and make this one first and so far just
sort of as you would imagine the best
the best kind of special in the match is
two of the puffer looking puffer fishes
together that makes one that is a big
explosion the others are pretty
comparable they all are useful for
certain things you'll get two levels
later where you'll have things that are
hard to get to for different reasons
and so you'll have to kind of engineer
the right special for the job but you
can see you're just making matches and
shooting the foam got it goes ahead and
takes it out for us and it's a pretty
straightforward level type
another combination here this one where
you can kind of see what the plus on it
it's a it'll shoot up and down like so
and we can clear the last one here and
so we just have one more to look at and
I'm going to load one of those up now
alright so the last one is the pearl
boards and they have like a little shell
and what we have to do is we have to
collect all the pearls you can see some
are open and some are closed when you
you open the clam up like so and then
you can match them together it's sort of
like a sort of like a egg and farm hero
song I guess we open it up you can't
match the closed ones with the open ones
but once you open up the toys where you
need to match all the open ones together
some some things to know about this
specials will collect them or they'll
open them like here's an open one during
a closed one you see what happens the
open one or the close the other one got
collected in the clothes when we came
open just matching them together
whoops and a lot of times I find that
the easiest way to get through these is
to just make a whole lot of specials so
that you can you know you can blast
through without actually matching them
together but I didn't have a really I
don't really have a lot of opportunity
to do that here so you just see regular
way
and you know this is the last one and
this is pretty much to be the end of
this video I'll make some specific this
specific videos for this game in the
different you know strategies that this
is popular but one of the things I
wanted to say before I finish this up
was I think this will be a game that
people will like because it's kind of
simpler you know it seems like what's
popular right now are a lot of the copy
games from candy crush you know like
your cookie jams and other games that
are basically just knockoff so the same
match-three style and I think what makes
those more popular as they're a little
bit easier not as cool in my opinion but
you know some players obviously
gravitate towards them and you know I
think this is kind of in that same
league like it's not it's not
unnecessarily difficult at least at this
point and it has gone through a lot of
changes so one thing that happens you
know graphics wise and stuff like that
but it's interesting about it to me is
it's a different matching mechanic you
know it's a totally different style of
play I don't think it's too complicated
that people won't you know take to it I
think that's sort of what happened with
some of the other games and like I said
why people like some of these games that
you know I don't think are as good so
hopefully you know it'll be popular and
people will enjoy it and I'll make a lot
of videos I have I'm almost at the end
now and I'll have them all done and
ready to go by the time the game is
released I think it should be you know
by August mid-august at the latest so
hopefully you'll enjoy it hopefully like
this video and you'll share it subscribe
to our channel to get more about this
and other new games when they come out
and leave a comment and let us know what
you think if you like some other games
and you haven't seen us making the
videos for those just let me know and
I'll see what I can do
all right thanks